donc elle vous pour l'ouverture d'un
centre de naturisme géant silva vous
habitez à kunié enseignements qu'on va
s'ouvrir kuni donc ce centre de nature
et patrick balkh et je comprends pas
qu'est-ce savez je vais vous dire ça
vous fait marrer mais vos collègues là
il est vrai il balance aussi sur vous un
japon comment vous montrez votre cul
partout en coulisse donc
excusez moi ou n'ai rien à main alors tu
ouvres h d'assumer venait un jour on
allait là bas non mais si ce n'est un
peu de respect tee shirt et sans rien en
dessous c'est quoi sinon oui donc vous
êtes nature y enlever le tee shirts
alors si vous êtes naturiste depuis
votre enfance
oui membres de l'association des
naturistes france en quoi va consister
ce centre donc y accueillir d'ici trois
ans 1300 maturité dans un complexe dédié
donc en seine et marne
oui oh c'est pas complexe le mot sais
pas si complexe que ça c'est tout
simplement un endroit où des gens vont
résider en permanence c'est à dire il y
aura des maisons classiques y aura des
équipements il y aura une piscine spa un
terrain de tennis une communauté
glaucome à une communauté une communauté
je dis oui enfin le mot communauté ça
renvoie communautariste non non ça leur
plaît vous médicaux des écoles c'est
qu'en dise maintenant j'ai bien sûr
parlé c'est du côté du stade une fois
vous avez aimé rire naturisme en soit
c'est une c'est une éducation voyez pas
ce qu'on éduque les gens par
l'exemplarité
mais on a besoin d'école pour ça il
suffit de voir les gens il suffit de
nous voir et là on apprend ce que c'est
que vous avez dit ferez vos écoles pour
des écrits j'assure évidemment ici on a
déjà il ya enfin dans ce pays un espèce
de tyrannie des minorités les
indigéniste un petit négrophobie etc il
ya ces gens là un vrai pareil parce
qu'il n'y pas vraiment donné sa première
avril ils ont quoi voulez me poser sa à
la société on s'en fout vivait comme
vous voulez mais je me suis emmerdé pas
le mandat pour extraire jeu s'il vous
plaît alors vous me comprenez que les
habitants dont une a eu ni françois
papoum qui est un centre naturiste âge
j'entends je respecte effectivement là
parler s'il vous plaît j'entends la
protestation mais comprendre non
certainement pas enfin variété ce
monsieur si bien compris fait partie des
villageois des minorités mais il
habitait la ville s'oppose minorité bail
majorité de gens vous savez il ya le
président du conseil général a déclaré
dans la presse je crois mot pour mot
c'était un bon prochain projet que ça
allait donner une image positive du
département alors cette année lui
représente la france c'est un élu de la
république
ironise absence d'un certain nombre
d'heures et pour répondre à ce que vous
dites c'est très drôle que vous parliez
de la tyrannie de la minorité par cinq
en général oui mais ce qu'on dit
monsieur vous le savez très bien mais
c'est la dictature de la majorité
et c'est très exactement je peux le slip
si elle apprécie votre équipe est elle a
justement parce que vous voyez où il a
exactement le style c'est la prison
pourquoi on a fait ça c'est pour
communiquer aussi par rapport aux
masques oui parce que l'enfermement ya
pas de petits enfants ni via l'avs le
pardon aux biopics maintenant ça va être
le masque oui c'est le vin ça c'est la
même chose c'est une camisole de masquer
ses quelque chose et je suis très
content qu'ils aient des masques enfants
je vous dis pourquoi pas ce que les gens
ressentent ce que c'est que la privation
de liberté ce que c'est que
l'enfermement et qui semblait imposé
grâce aux filières existent active s'est
passé comme un masque est ce quelque
chose qu'on mais c'est peut-être pas
grand-chose c'est un petit morceau
d'étoffé
mais c'est quand même une privation de
liberté qu'est ce que vous voulez mais
l'année voulait faire passer comme il
est je comprends son jt mettra masque
lui bien lancée moi par exemple j'ai mis
oui vous pouvez monter votre centre dans
les règles qui seront imposées mais par
contre que vous veniez sur le plateau
dévêtue ça me dérange pas son préféré
jean frédéric poisson posées par le tout
est dit et alors que moi j'étais chez
moi on n'est pas là pour vous me posez
votre rockies la couleur de
l'agressivité vous me posez votre tenue
excusez moi moi je considère que c'est
bon mais on n'a pas le droit d'être nu
on n'a pas le droit c'est interdit pas
c'est justement le problème c'est
précisément parce qu'on aura le dessus
et vous allez devoir même mais oui eric
naulleau non mais en quoi ça dérange et
je représente en fait le conseil
municipal de cluny et ce qui me dérange
c'est pas forcément le centre de
naturisme un centre dans le domaine de
chiron il ya 47 hectares qui sont des
déjà dédié à cette pratique déviante
pourquoi rajouter dans cette commune
bon après personnellement voilà moi je
suis venu m'installer avec ma famille
alors dans le domaine afin ac unis pour
j'essaie de travailler pour une paisible
en poche
[Rires]
pour l'ouverture d'un centre de
naturisme géant comprenez que ça me
gênait des habitants mais encore une
fois d'abord si les plantes il aurait dû
demander aux habitants s'ils sont
d'accord
moi personnellement il peut venir ça me
gêne pas et le président du conseil je
parlais il ya un propos intelligents le
droit c'est moi mon arrivée je connais
très bien j'ai plein de potes nous avons
totalisé on n'est pas de souci que les
gens indique vivre à poil mais c'est
leur problème c'est pas bien et après
captiver le saint père faisait là moi
mais qu'il dise à la commune est ce que
vous êtes d'accord ça mais ça m'a aussi
logique mais moi je préfère cent fois
qui est sa nature ni ce que le
prisonnier à courir
il a emmené par contre si jamais si
jamais les jeunes gens racontent qu'ils
vont te disais non même d'ailleurs se
demander quand même que le maire ou fait
que jed demande est et restera un jour
un tournoi des six nations naturiste oui
quand on regarde ce mois ci manque de
respect ça me saoule à tout le monde
qu'il faudra mettre à l'essai un minimum
de respect quand c'est une dérive c'est
une vraie dérive le mec et se sont
libres de se promener on attentat à la
pudeur a devancé aux enfants qui
regardent l'émission penser aux ados je
m'en vais ça devait arriver c'est bojan
médias
c'est très difficile d'être la minorité
effective nommez moi je fais un script
non mais attendez la conversation je
pense qu'effectivement la musique sans
la nudité fait partie de la civilisation
européenne depuis toujours
surtout dans l'art d'ailleurs moi ce qui
me gêne franchement dans cette
entreprise
ce sont les enfants parce qu'en fait les
adultes à la limite mais c'est vrai ils
font ce qu'ils veulent mais ils
s'organiser comme ils veulent c'est un
lieu privé donc moi j'ai pas à dire sa
forme quand les gens dans un lieu privé
en revanche si le lieu privé est
accessible visuellement pour des enfants
ou si effectivement les adultes seront à
se promener en dehors de ce lieu privé
tels que monsieur se promène sur ce
plateau ici moi j'ai des enfants je
n'aimerais pas qu'il voit ça mais voilà
si je suis un bon enfant dès maintenant
les adultes qui font ce qu'ils veulent
nous sommes dans un pays libre monsieur
n'a pas compris le fonctionnement 10 ans
et d'adhérer à une association
dès l'instant qu'on adhère à
l'association on adhère aux valeurs ça
veut dire que tous les gens à
l'intérieur du des résidences seront
qu'on s'entend bien sur et harris maesa
pur c'est scandaleux franchement s'il
vous plaît c'est du communautarisme
monsieur moi j'ai sous les yeux une
délibération du conseil municipal de
cluny qui date du 8 octobre 2019 ou le
conseil municipal à l'unanimité à
l'unanimité moins une abstention s'est
déclaré favorable
voilà à l'accord l'action naturiste
aussi c'est peut-être légal mais est-ce
que c'est souhaitable wallace est
souhaitable que les gens ne vivent que
entourés de leurs semblables parce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas se mélanger une
société qui dérape des gens habillés ne
peuvent pas entrer dans cette ville de
gaza on va on va c'est à dire une
société où tout le monde s'est pris des
allures un cercle fermé avec uniquement
des gens qui voulaient sanctionner
monsieur le travail dans son coin il va
tech ses potes à poil donc essayer ce
qui me reprochent c'est en fait ce sont
les dérives c'est à dire que dans un
premier temps ses 1300 nudistes qui vont
arriver plus les gens qui vont venir
autour en elecam et nous on nous enterre
les voiliers à venir ces gens autour si
les problèmes assez mobile semblaient
mais ils ont un regard sa licence sur la
naturisme cenon demandant de venir je
vais pas des bourses j'ai entendu pardon
madame n'a pas toute la france entière
qui va pouvoir changer de travail juste
de venir habiter à qu'univers pour faire
penser alors un sens si vous avez des
enfants vous mélanger deux choses je
suis pas adepte du naturisme à mercy bay
permet quoi méridien néanmoins je
respecte ceux qui le font et c'est pas
parce qu'on est naturiste qu'on est
pervers
côté l'art de vivre soit c'est plutôt
les électrons autour voyez c'est à dire
servir lloris masse que saint-cyr comme
vous le dites vous même les vrais
pervers sont à l'extérieur ils sont pas
à l'intérieur n'avait pas peur ici ça
veut dire vous refusez de vous mélangez
avec des gens différents vous voulez
vivre qu'avec des gens qui partagent
exactement nos valeurs c'est le
contraire de la vie en société qu'est ce
qui vous dérange c'est bien ce qui les
rend jamais jamais vu c'est la première
fois depuis la première voire essieux de
monsieur monsieur franchement et ça
s'appelle de l'exhibitionnisme n'ont pas
vu leurs effectifs une infraction
j'aimerais essentielle est-ce qu'il vous
plaît on délire totalement mais c'est
une urgence à construire un centre pour
naturistes
il ya dans ce lieu donc c'était une
ancienne dynamiterie on aurait vu le
voilà installé c'est là un lieu de
mémoire pour faire mal a même lancé des
grenades à la place et au combien un
hôpital non mais c'est sa voisine qu'un
centre culture de violence et de guerre
et nous à ce procès ait lieu ça fait 35
ans qui se passe absolument rien à cet
endroit là nous on redonne de la vie
redonne même je vais vous dire une âme à
ce lieu voilà et comme vous l'avez dit
le conseil a voté donc y avait le
problème c'est pas le centre le vous
levez vous balader
le montrer excusez moi le centre cac et
quelques paris pose des règles donc si
on n'a pas envie de voir votre cul on
n'y va pas par un q pour vous c'est pas
le corps humain sur mon avis cela s'il
vous plaît moi aussi je lui dis bonjour
m'a dit qu'il est cool je sais où le
sommeil à macul allez merci monsieur
choqué kiwi regardez rond à l'unanimité
tant à l'unanimité oui vous êtes tous
les deux mais moi je suis là pour
débattre monsieur limité merci écouter à
l'asie avec vous mon petit kilo j'ai à
dire je réponds pas même sac
j'ai arrêté ça batteur will miss you
play son banjo de quelqu'un servier
souffler sur play 2002 minute deux
minutes mais le tennessee où plein s'il
vous plaît messieurs s'il vous plaît
l'ambiance ils ont pété les corps les
chéris la main c'est non merci ça va ah
[ __ ] oui moi c'est la fin de session
s'est passé des simples et élégants et
carris et booba ou même genre les
floralies floride
comment c'est bon merci c'est bon pour y
aller flory qu'est ce qu'on fait avec
l'écran soit sûr et ils sont ils sont
mort gelé mais surtout réussi à péter
les prendre le petit là que ça dure une
vision qui dit mic remettre nos mails
annales s'offusque mais j'étais juste
une remarque à l'écran ce qui se passe
avec les granges laurence fait un devis
depuis ça sent bon on va voir mettez
mettais un truc qui doit le moins
embêtés avec la couleur mon avis en noir
symbole - non rouge que rouge normaux
laisser ta sont pour l'instant ils font
mais là vous n'avez pas cherché la
faille au lavage ah oui il est bien été
déclenchée
non allez s'il vous plaît pour l'instant
brooke est bon et c'est comme ça voilà
allez on y va s'il vous plaît les
missions de ces milieux naturels a
séparé ses dons alors je suis sûr merci
ils vont ils vont s'arranger tout s'est
arrangé ne vous inquiétez pas voilà ils
ont pris le taxi comme ça ils ont peur
ils sont très bien